previously on TV since I really have no
idea what's going on dear do you think
it's coincidence your being here things
that could have been brought to my
attention yesterday did he just run
straight up a cliff face barefoot good
to know the show is establishing early
on that we should throw out all of our
weird fascinations with the actual laws
of physics also this dude sees a boat
and wants to signal it but the first 20
seconds of this show is arrow running
through the dense woods and I'll put
giant rock to get in position rather did
you see this boat in the first place you
might give me a ton of explanations and
all of them might be right but that's
the consequence of starting your show
with 20 seconds of goddamn shaky cam
quick editing and uncertain geography
the name of the island they found me on
is Lian Yu it's Mandarin for the island
of convenient back stories also aeration
I can only assume that this shot means
we will get some awesome Deathstroke in
this show later on and then it'll be
handled brilliantly and not wasted
because if not well I've been stranded
here for five years which is just long
enough to seem like I'd be really good
with a bow and arrow but not so long
that I'm too old for our key demo to put
up my posters and swim also show
promises at least five seasons worth of
flashbacks before it's even picked up
for a second season i think w EBG needs
better scroll writers if you're going to
have every other story on the scroll be
about Queen being discovered maybe have
it say something different than both the
news anchor and the giant title right
above it is already saying Queen was a
regular tabloid presence and a fixture
at the Starling city club scene
why does Ollie Bieber Queen here choose
to go after the paparazzi that is
farthest away from him when this click
him it click ursin to his left is
already all up in his face Clara I'd
like you to prepare yourself he Oliver
you lost might not be the one they found
because your psychiatrist as well does
this mean that his sister didn't go see
him in the hospital he's been missing
five years and she just chills in a room
until he can make it to the mansion rich
people truly are the worst huh also
Willa Holland is apparently going to
make a career out of playing siblings
two crazy people the queen's gambit was
last heard from more than five years ago
we know this story has already been out
for a while so why is this entire law
office gathered around this report like
it's breaking news I mean seven of them
are sitting around the table like they
were in some sort of meeting was it a
meeting to watch the local news DC
comics good thing that remotes somehow
walked all the way to the end of the
table or nobody decided to stand so
could have this overly dramatic moment
after five years everything that was
once familiar is now unrecognizable like
windows curtains this mirror and I
needed to get the butler to help me
figure out what we call these shelves we
put the books on the face I see in the
mirror is a stranger it's not your face
the camera seems focused on Oliver today
print must have and be willing to show
spectacular body right in the CW teen
drama contract not that it's peculiar
that they want to highlight stephen
amell 'he's absolutely stunning physique
I mean I'm not saying he's completely
turned me but I now maybe a tad bit
bisexual wait was his flashback sneaking
up on him from behind
apparently that flashbacks lasted long
enough for him to get dressed and head
downstairs nice Tommy Merlyn I've missed
you boy
and I missed saying your full name to
you when I see you like all friends do
cuz that's normal and stuff
oh and lost they were all dead I think
spoiler alert also you think wrong I
didn't realize you took Russian at
college 11 I didn't realize you wanted
to sleep with my mother Walter
oh yes Queen Slayer but considering this
comes out of nowhere does it really have
the impact it should yeah we're gonna be
fine character says we're going to be
fine right before disaster strikes and a
bunch of people die in a television show
cliche like that but Tommy Boy wasn't
anywhere near that conversation so how
can he be sure he knows how it went at
all and why would she even ask him that
question alright that's what qualifies
as humor in the DC CW carry on are you
serious
a Taser directly to the [ __ ] heart
and Oliver just spits up a little what
did he tell you mr. Queen discount red
skull here make sure that we know he's
evil by doing the full drastic double
head tilt a move perfected by movie
villains and done by no one ever in real
life is it cuff to that chair not
anymore
every time a hero gives away the element
of surprise to try and sound badass with
a coupie comeback an angel loses its
wings probably with a chainsaw I'm
guessing look I don't make the rules
also are you telling me that in the five
years he was on the island he had enough
forethought to train himself how to get
out of zipper ties what did he use like
seaweed in the history of elemental
competition there are only two mysteries
that shall never be understood how paper
beats Rock and how chair beats a group
of three armed gunmen hi my name is
Frank and I'm the kind of henchman that
stands over here with this machine gun
for about 15 seconds waiting until one
of my buddies is in the way before
shooting for some reason hi Frank also
even if using a human body work and none
of the bullets carried through to Oliver
you're telling me that not a single one
of those bullets hit his arm or his face
[Music]
so we're rooting for a straight-up
murder in this show cool cool being a
superhero is back-breaking work I guess
what do I call you
Diggle worm dirt dig alert giggles
getting giggly with it diggle's good
party pooper do we have an agreement sir
okay I know Lightning McQueen spent five
years on origin story island developing
his stealth skill and whatnot but there
is no way you've disappear like that
from a moving vehicle being driven by an
ex-military bodyguard with full access
to his rear view mirror also he jumped
out of the moving vehicle while carrying
the bag and the backpack for a guy who
wants to keep his arrows secret this
seems to be a terrible way to do it sure
maybe nobody will believe a couple of
homeless people but you went through
great pains to kill hardened criminals
to make sure they couldn't tell anybody
your secret the abduction was unexpected
it forced me to move up my plans are we
getting narrated that again we are
halfway through this pilot so shouldn't
you a force-fed us all the exposition we
need by now what's that you're gonna do
it again at least twice more before the
episode is over
well this origin story is so Batman that
DC should sue themselves for this the CW
must save a lot of overhead on male
shirts since 67% of the time they are
not required to wear one
what's the CW also behind the mani so if
little green hiding hun had to roll out
of a car to shake Diggle let's grant the
bag in the backpack but how exactly did
he get this giant crate here with no one
being the wiser
also how exactly did he get that through
customs so I get that he took out the
light above them with an arrow of some
sort but why did that also turn off
every single light on the sides I think
is like Christmas lights were one bad
bulb affects the whole chain you missed
of course he did because apparently
Oliver is immune from bullets he was
wearing a hood a green hood and he had a
bow and arrow so it was Robin Hood
Legolas Daryl Dixon you're not really
narrowing it down here boss what the
hell's going on out there across the
street party for the guy that got
rescued off that Island Oliver Queen
you're telling me that Oliver's party is
across the street so when all the arrow
stuff goes down you don't think the cops
might make a connection all it takes is
like 30 seconds of thought and whose
arrow mystery is solved which one is she
the one who looks like the chick from
Twilight
what's Twilight there's
better off not knowing is one of these
girls actually supposed to look like
Kristen Stewart or is this all just an
excuse to make a lame Twilight joke I'm
guessing it's the second thing you died
my brother and my father died amazing
they can have this normal conversation
in the middle of a dance floor with all
that playing at full volume when she
died did she suffer no I mean have you
watched legends of tomorrow I might beg
to differ is this sappy musics supposed
to make me buy into some sort of sexual
tension between Laurel and discount
Hardy here we've seen them together one
other time in which she rightfully hated
him for getting her sister killed
sure we've been told they had something
before but has enough time passed for us
to find any of this believable something
off I asked somebody to do something
head into it why even pronoun game your
way around this explanation it's not
like you have to tell her anything just
make something up or say no and move on
right convenient time to wake up is
convenient seriously how can no one hit
Oliver with a goddamn gun did you even
try to save him did you even try to save
my daughter
well isn't that a nice little Oliver
Twist here's the problem there is no
story reason why that information is
more important now than it was when we
first met this detective in fact knowing
that information could have made for a
deeper understanding of relationship
dynamics for this entire episode TVs got
a TV I guess also the Starling city not
have any other police officers that
could handle this case Whitten being
Sarah's dad makes him heading up this
case the definition of a conflict of
interest some point since me u.s. gonna
have your party here and hunt getting
robbed right next door and by the same
guy who rescued us at the warehouse damn
it token bestfriend character would be
amazing a TV since also why did he use
the word robbed nobody said anything
about hunt getting robbed the detective
guy said there was an incident and an
attack but nothing about a robbery how
did he do it
oh come on every single other arrow is
cleaned up in the entire rooms being put
back together
but they left this one arrow that looks
like it has some computer on it just
sticking to the wall also I didn't
greenie just shoot this magic
combination router decrypt her arrow was
somewhere in the room that was a little
less obvious than behind the desk at eye
level also also didn't Oliver learn
awesome hacking techniques while he was
on you know an island signifying a money
transfer with a progress bar and a
rapidly changing dollar amount cliche
this fall on the CW the green list so
why in the name of [ __ ] arrow hanging
around this very fire escape right now
he just gleaned some awesome personal
information bye
creeping around here good for him she
says the island changed me for five
years I've had only one thought one goal
survive what do I call you
they call me mr. Tibbs thank you very
considerate just tell me where you want
yeah I'll tell you what I want what I
really really want so tell me what you
want what you really really want